[Music]
time for one more thing Kimberly I thank
you Greg and today I want to honor a
very special mom her friends referred to
her as a super mom and superwoman and
that is beautiful sweet Carrie Galvin
she was 31 years young amazing human
being a mother to three incredible
children and she and her husband Justin
was a former Marine who served in Iraq
attended the console on vacation in
Vegas and they were just a hundred yards
from the stage when the gunman opened
fire and carries very sadly and
tragically died in her husband's arms
this you know hits particularly close to
home my brother and his girlfriend
Geneva brought this to my attention as a
family friend and you can visit my
twitter page to learn more about Carrie
and about how you can help her family
this young man much like my father had
to do with my brother and I when our
mother dies he's gonna have to raise
these three very special children I hope
they know how wonderful their mother is
and on another note